[Musique]
par les enfants romano john connor
louche or nous sommes arrivés nounours
nous sommes arrivés enfin très loyal
baume
rahman al amana gens louches or
qu'est-ce que c'est que ça c'est curieux
romanow aux majors bush
révèle afin d'être en forme et
petits-enfants qu'elle voyage qu'elle
voyage merveilleux
oui j'ai été gâté ce qu'ils sont gentils
c'est vrai qu'à moi j'ai une bonne chose
[Musique]
commence un froid matin bonne mine oui
tu as des bonnes grilles ou qu'est ce
qu'il ya dans cette vallée du lot
surprise c'est faux oui tout est beau
mais si une telle union allons allons
pas de précipitation sefra juin
voici d'abord deux images très précieuse
de mignotte
[Musique]
et puis voici un se rhabiller
ça sert à savoir l'heure c'est une
montre un doux très pratique pour la
cuisine la cuisine et voilà pour nicolas
oui c'est très joli vin
est pour toi un superbe sari en soit ce
qu'ils les jeunes y est voilà des gros
lots qui sommait beaucoup des bus 1 et
des téléphones
c'est un vrai magasin et mali ce n'est
pas pour
voilà pas trop arrive tenez les enfants
voici encore un pot libre comme à donner
mon grand ami le maharadja mais la nappe
à carreaux
dommage vous raconterai l'histoire
prenais grand soin de ma valise elle est
encore plein de choses à
admirable d'un janot roues
et bah de flûte pour charmer
ses cailloux ce sont des pierres
précieuses
je vous les donne j'en ai toute une
collection je vous la montrerai un jour
quand vous serez très sage
la patron voilà
je me sens les enfants nés à demain
[Musique]
dépêche-toi nounours le cher petit si
vous aviez vu langeois patron alan en
route tu pourras enlever cette urbain
nous sommes plus aux indes allons ses
coiffures m'a vachement bien et je
trouve que j'ai l'air d'amara cha ne te
fâche pas c'est vrai tu es très beau
comme ça
bonne nuit les enfants fait pour
on
ouais
encore
[Musique]